[Music]
[Applause]
modest heroes is the second film out of
studio panic who made last year's mary
and the witches flower and this film is
an anthology it has three animated short
films all three of them feature stories
of someone who does something heroic and
it's not necessarily about the heroic
deed but it's about their lives and then
at some point they're called to do
something heroic and they decide to step
up and do it the first is called
Canadian Canino and it's about two
siblings who live underwater and while
their mother goes away to give birth
their father and then gets swept away in
the stream and they have a tiny little
adventure involving this really big fish
they're afraid of the second is called
life ain't gonna lose and it's about a
mother trying to raise a boy who has a
very severe egg allergy and all of the
problems that come with that and the
very last one is called invisible and
it's about someone who is invisible but
you could take it metaphorically or you
could take it literally and and I have
things to say about that one in
particular so I was very curious about
the production of this because usually
anime short films are very uncommon
especially with distribution even the
great ones from Studio Ghibli play only
at the Ghibli Museum usually and so it's
really hard to see those even there's
plenty I'd love to see but I just don't
have access to them this is an attempt
from Studio Pollack to support people
who want to make a short anime film
which i think is great I was sent a
press release from G kids that had an
interview with people who worked as
studio ponic and they talked about how
after marrying the witch's flower they
were just really exhausted they were
tired there's so much you know work went
into something is hand drawing like that
not a perfect anime film and not one of
my favorites but visually stunning for
sure all that being said they were like
we want to make another film but that's
gonna take a long time for us to get
going again and we need a kind of a
break but the idea of making short anime
films could spread the work out a little
bit and allow them to make an anthology
which is now becoming the studio ponic
short film theatre and this is marketed
as the first volume and so hopefully
we'll get more anthologies that have
other short films from anime directors
and writers because I really
love the idea of supporting that form of
filmmaking because we don't usually get
a lot of that and I think short films
are something that should be supported a
lot more especially animated short films
so the first short is from the director
of when Marnie was there which is one of
my favorite Studio Ghibli films of
recent years and while this film feels
kind of inconsequential I did really
like the way it looked it was
beautifully drawn and animated but it
didn't really have much weight to it the
imagery was gorgeous and they did a good
job of making something that to most
people isn't that frightening rather
scary this fish that's after them to us
the fish means nothing but seeing it
from their perspective it really it
really was amazing the second film with
the mother and the son with the egg
allergy I like the animation for this
even more one of the things I can
definitely say is that with each film
the animation got better I thought the
first movie is a lot more traditional
that Studio Ghibli look the the second
one has a little bit more of a painted
feel to it also this one I liked in
particular though because as a short
it's able to take moments that most
films would treat as small and make them
a lot grander but the third one
invisible was easily my favorite this is
stunning and I love the idea behind it
to someone who is wearing clothes you
can see him put on his tie his glasses
and he's at work and he's typing but you
don't see his fingers you just see the
keys on the keyboard moving up and down
people don't notice him but he
apparently has a job he has a place to
live so in some way he obtained these
things which is why I like the idea of
this short perhaps just being a metaphor
for being really lonely and feeling like
no one notices you and literally feeling
invisible but this film takes it and
puts it in a way that creates such a
feeling of isolation there's one
incredible sequence that actually gave
me chills where he feels like he is
being pulled off the earth like gravity
is suddenly not affecting him anymore
and he's just lifting off into the sky
floating away and nobody even notices
this however though is a very short
movie it's already just three short
films and even then it's not even a full
hour and there's credits in between each
one what makes this even more
unfortunate is that the Great East out
acha hot I was originally going to
direct
of forth shorts that would have been
included in this anthology but he passed
away so that's really sad but it could
have been a lot longer it could have
been you know a little bit more
impactful it had a little bit more
staying power but I think the reason I
really want to support this movie is
purely the concept of studio ponic
lifting up short form filmmaking
especially in animation and giving it a
venue and giving it distribution this is
really really good if this movie makes
enough money if enough people go and see
it hopefully we can have a small little
franchise of anime shirt film
anthologies which is just a whole unique
new thing that we could appreciate I can
never have enough anime and so naturally
I'm excited about that possibility the
biggest issue with the movie really is
its length it can feel very forgettable
because it's just three short films and
they're just they're gone it's done and
then okay well I appreciated that but
what did that really tell me I I think
I'm more excited about what this could
bring in the future if it does well
enough then what this is although I
definitely enjoyed myself watching it
and each one had its charms and each one
was unique enough to recommend I'm gonna
give modest heroes a be guys thank you
so much as always for watching this week
is gonna be fun I have glass and the
Dragon Ball super movie I thought about
seeing replicas but I think I have
something else to do so I think I just
decided to skip that one I do want to
make my most overlooked and underrated
movies of 2018 so I'm gonna be working
on that as well guys thank you so much
once again and if you liked this you can
click right here and get stuck mine eyes
[Music]